[Music]
work is underway to create a new
smithsonian national museum of the
american latino in washington d.c with
nearly 20 percent of the u.s population
or more than 60 million people latinos
or people of hispanic origin they're the
fastest growing minority group in the
country and the effort to build a museum
that reflects so much diversity is a
years-long undertaking ed o'keefe spoke
with some of the key players
[Applause]
when you think of latinos in america
what comes to mind
music
food
[Applause]
theater
but also supreme court justices business
owners athletes veterans a massive block
of voters with buying power of nearly
two trillion dollars
and now all of that history will be
housed in a new smithsonian museum the
national museum of the american latino i
think we need to disabuse viewers of the
notion that somehow this is forbidden
about us right it's for everyone eduardo
diaz is acting director of the museum to
be why is this museum needed i think
latinos are so foundational and we're
growing still and we're going to be here
i think it's a good opportunity for you
to get to know us a little bit better
diaz already has a team of 16 curators
working across the smithsonian system so
what can visitors expect to see at the
new museum
diaz says it'll start before america was
well america these people our indigenous
people were here right before the
arrival of europeans from there it'll
cover the span of u.s latino history
from the u.s mexico war the possession
of puerto rico subjects like immigration
you'll see a cuban balsa a raft that
cuban refugees used to cross from cuba
to the united states i mean it's built
out of styrofoam and duct tape you know
what kind of courage it took to get in
that boat like a plaza and coming next
spring a temporary exhibit housed in the
american history museum that'll showcase
some of what will eventually move to the
new home this will be it this is the
molina gallery after decades of intense
lobbying congress last year approved
plans for the new museum it's expected
to cost hundreds of millions of dollars
with congress footing half the bill and
private fundraising paying for the rest
that's where some of the biggest names
in latino business and entertainment
like music producer emilio estefan come
in the latino community i think is going
to come true in a big way we want to
become very creative because
realistically raise that amount of money
you don't need a million dollars it's
some people if every latino we give five
dollars that makes a the number i like
your idea though if every latino gave
five dollars would be all set i'm going
to send you a any number we have to send
you five dollars
emilio immigrated from cuba and
eventually launched the miami sound
machine with his wife gloria stefan
i think a lot of people take the united
states for granted we don't take it for
granted we try get to recognize that
that we're blessed the board will not
only be helping raise money but also
advise what goes in the museum
estefan is joined by a diverse group of
latino leaders from across business
retail and entertainment including sofia
vergara jose andres and eva longoria
exactly where the museum gets built is
still part of a classic washington fight
we are of one mind on this this is not a
debate by law the museum's board of
trustees includes two members of
congress and california democrat tony
cardinis and washington state republican
jaime editor butler agree the museum
needs to be on the mall that beautiful
swath of land that goes from the united
states capital all the way past the
washington monument it was actually
created for monuments and museums
potential locations include the famed
arts and industries building an
agriculture department building on the
mall or an area just outside the capitol
either way members of the board expect
the museum to tell latino success
stories and to focus on the importance
of family latino history is american
history and without our story being told
so that people in this country and
people in the world can see how
beautiful our country is and what we
contribute as latinos i think it's going
to help tell the story of a more perfect
union the momentum behind this is just
critical
it it it's critical and it's critical
that we pass that on i cannot wait to
take my children
for cbs mornings i'm ed o'keefe
in washington
i'm so glad they're doing that i love mr
diaz when he said
it's a chance for people to get to know
us a little better yeah and latino
history is american history i think it's
so important that this is happening
that's right shout out to all of our
latino brothers and sisters including ed
o'keefe don't be fooled by the last name
no doubt about it and that that museum
will be a reflection
of how much they are appreciated in this
country and around the world and the
difference they made yeah no doubt about
it and then your five dollars